dortmund hamm bienenbüttel passau
düsseldorf esslingen berlin alles
tatorte schrecklicher bluttaten alles
grausame ereignisse die innerhalb von
nur einer woche stattfinden ein großteil
der verbrechen verübt von psychisch
belasteten menschen und in der nacht sie
sehen die bilder der nächste dramatische
tat in mannheim ein mann der zuvor
seinen vater umgebracht haben soll fährt
auf der flucht vier radfahrer an eine
71-jährige frau stirbt drei weitere
werden schwer verletzt
so viele gräueltaten in nur einer woche
dortmund haben bienen wird
düsseldorf esslingen passau berlin es
sind grausame taten sie zeigen das
dunkelste der menschlichen seele werden
sie zum schrecklichen alltag wie krank
ist deutschland immer wieder eskaliert
die gewalt entschließen sich menschen
willkürlich in der öffentlichkeit zu
töten sie sorgen für fassungslosigkeit
entsetzen trauer
alleine angst aus dem haus zu gehen
sondern ausreichend ja
etwas was in den menschen vorgeht
dortmund ein 56-jähriger mann schlägt
spätnachts in dortmund hörde mehrfach
mit einem stumpfen gegenstand auf den
kopf seiner frau ein fügt ihr schwerste
schädelverletzungen zu tötet sie auf
brutalste art und weise nach eintreffen
der polizei stürzte er sich aus dem
fenster auch er stirbt die gemeinsamen
12 und 13 jährigen söhne sehen alles mit
an das furchtbare die tat hätte
womöglich verhindert werden können der
mann stellt sich kurz zuvor wohl selbst
in einer psychiatrischen klinik vor
bittet um hilfe um aufnahme
der mann hat nämlich selber gemerkt dass
er hilfe braucht er soll den staaten
drang verspürt haben sich und anderen
gewalt anzutun und ist deshalb in eine
psychiatrische klinik gefahren um sich
da selber einweisen zu lassen aber man
soll ihn mit den worten nach hause
geschickt haben er solle sich am montag
an seinen hausarzt wenden die
staatsanwaltschaft bestätigt der mann
leidet unter psychischen problemen
[Musik]
nur einen tag zuvor nicht weit von
dortmund entfernt in den gängen und
einem hörsaal der hochschule
hamm-lippstadt greift der 34 jährige
psychologie student markus er wahllos
mit gerade erst gekauften küchenmessern
frauen nun männerhand er sticht seine
opfer inhalt gesicht bauch und
brustbereich er verletzt er tötet eine
30 jährige frau aus essen er liegt am
sonntag ihren schweren verletzungen
markus er hatte schon länger psychische
probleme er fühlte sich verfolgt
erbitterte überall feinde und er glaubte
dass man ihn und seine eltern umbringen
wolle ja und zwei tage vor der tat da
hat er versucht sich das leben zu nehmen
und war deshalb freiwillig in einer
psychiatrischen klinik untergebracht
aber auch hier holten ihn seine
wahnvorstellungen einer glaubte die
kläger wollten ihn vergiften und deshalb
hat er sich kurzerhand selber entlassen
er kauft und an die beiden küchenmesser
und hat dann hier in der hochschule in
haben diesen amoklauf gestartet und
möglicherweise hätte auch diese tat
verhindert werden können denn erst im
april hat er bei der polizei wegen
seiner angeblichen verfolger anzeige
erstattet aber man glaubte es liegt
weder eigen noch eine fremdgefährdung
vor
markus er fühlt sich regelrecht von
seiner umwelt verfolgt bedroht seine
feinde wittert er unter anderem in
seiner uni es wird eine einstweilige
unterbringung in einem psychiatrischen
krankenhaus angeordnet
bienenbüttel das verstörende ende eines
jahrelangen nachbarschaftsstreit um ein
paar bäume ein 85 jähriger jäger
erschießt seine 61 jährige nachbarin und
ihren 62 jahre alten mann richtet sich
kurz darauf selbst der grund das ehepaar
möchte am grundstück bäume fällen ihr
nachbar ist dagegen sieht rot tötet
düsseldorf ein brutaler mord schock die
düsseldorfer altstadt mit einem
gusseisernen begrenzungspoller schlägt
ein 55 jähriger obdachloser am ratinger
tor auf einen 23 jährigen ein der
tatverdächtige versuchte zu fliehen kann
jedoch von einsatzkräften festgenommen
werden für den jungen mann aus bayern
kommt jede hilfe zu spät er stirbt noch
am tatort
esslingen
großeinsatz im bereich der
katharinenschule ein mann bringt morgens
in die grundschule esslingen ein greift
mit einem küchenmesser eine 61 jährige
betreuerin und eine siebenjährige
schülerin an fügt ihnen schwerste
stichverletzungen zu hinterlässt am
tatort einen rucksack voll mit weiteren
messern er wird einen ganzen tag lang
gejagt meldet sich dann selbst bei der
polizei der mutmaßliche tatverdächtige
ein 24-jähriger mit niederländischem
pass er wird festgenommen
seine opfer überleben
passau ein 86 jähriger tötet hier nach
aktuellem ermittlungsstand wohl seine 85
jährige ehefrau sowie seine 59 jahre
alten sohn anschließend versuchte er
sich selbst zu töten in einer
notoperation kann sein
gesundheitszustand zunächst stabilisiert
werden
berlin wenn liebe in hass endet ein 37
jähriger schlägt mit einem hammer auf
seine schwangere ex frau ein zerschlägt
erst die terrassentür dann visiert er
ihren kopf an trifft dabei aber ihren
babybauch das ungeborene kind grund der
unfassbaren attacke das kind ist nicht
von ihm nach der trennung wird sie von
einem anderen schwanger das lässt den 37
jährigen offenbar durch drehen und die
todesfahrt des 29 jährigen psychisch
kranken gora um kurz vor halb elf lautes
motoren dröhnen am berliner kudamm der
deutsch armenier lenkt den silbergrauen
renault clio seiner schwester in eine
menschenmenge er tötet die 51 jährige
lehrerin tanja h verletzt mehrere ihrer
schüler der zehnten klasse aus bad
arolsen teils lebensgefährlich es ist
ihre abschlussfahrt nach berlin eine 200
meter lange schneise der verwüstung
zieht sich über den boulevard am ende
steckt der kleinwagen in einem
schaufenster einer parfümerie boa er
leidet an paranoider schizophrenie wird
in einer psychiatrischen anstalt
untergebracht
die schrecklichen taten nur einer woche
deutschland in angst in sorge man fühlt
sich nirgends mehr sicher ob das berlin
ist frankfurt ob das wir waren in boston
es ist überall
irgendwas ist immer
sie können von glück reden wenn sie
abends in ihrem bett liegen und es ist
alles gut es ist wohnen hier in der nähe
und
es verunsichert ein aber eigentlich
fühle ich mich schon noch sicher muss
ich sagen
dortmund haben bienenbüttel
düsseldorf esslingen passau und berlin
hätten diese taten verhindert werden
können oder haben die behörden aus ihren
fehlern der vergangenheit etwa nichts
gelernt
ja und jetzt bei uns zugeschaltet ist
innenminister herbert reul als nordrhein
westfalen jetzt hier bei uns schön dass
sie sich die zeit nehmen heraus wie
sicher ist deutschland
nach deutschland ist sicher das muss man
schon sagen aber zu glauben wir hätten
hier 100 prozent sicherheit das gibt
sowieso nicht auf der welt es gibt es
auch in deutschland nicht aber wir haben
eine menge fragen zu beantworten müssen
an vielen stellen immer noch besser
werden ich kann mich erinnern dass sie
vor ein paar jahren schon mal gesagt
habe merkwürdigerweise sind die großen
anschläge die wir erleben gar nicht mehr
die von islamisten oder von rechts oder
links extremisten sondern meistens nur
kombination oft menschen die krank
psychisch krank sein und wir müssen uns
darum kümmern und leider häuft sich das
jetzt wir sind bei der mit gut bei
diesem vorgang relativ in schwierigen
fragen
also es ist in der tat wie sie sagen
nicht nur ein gefühl dass es vermehrt
auftritt sondern die zahlen belegen dass
ja auch ich meinen innerhalb von einer
woche diese ganzen schrecklichen taten
gewesen gerade auch in unserem film
gesehen haben wie müssen sie wie muss
die politik jetzt gegensteuern was muss
unbedingt getan werden soll
das erste ist man muss zur kenntnis
nehmen es gibt dieses problem wir haben
ein problem von straftätern die wir in
unseren blickwinkel nicht vorsehen haben
menschen die psychische erkrankungen
haben und kriminelle vorgänge manchmal
auffällig geworden sind und wir brauchen
dafür antwort ich weiß dass das
ungeheuer schwierig ist weil wir ja im
zusammenhang mit datenschutz auch mit
gerade mit den krankenakten sehr
behutsamen vorgehen müssen aber eins
habe ich gelernt augen zu machen hilft
nix und deswegen haben wir ja noch den
westfalen versucht mit dem pre scope
also der versuch zu machen einfach ja
ein wenig wachsamer durch die welt zu
gehen um es mal vorsichtig vorzutragen
danach haben wir natürlich die tatsache
jetzt beispielsweise hier in wellen
diene die hinterbliebenen der lehrerin
aber auch ja alle angehörigkeit alle
angehörigen der schüler jetzt hier dort
ist ein mann einfach in eine
menschenmenge gerast dann heißt das er
ist psychisch krank und damit ist der
fall erledigt und für all die menschen
die dort involviert sein bleibt die
frage nach dem warum und hätte das nicht
verhindert werden können muss ich da
müssen sich die behörden da besser
austauschen müssen da andere
informationen stattfinden es gibt so oft
warnzeichen hat man den eindruck die
einfach übersehen werden oder nicht
wahrgenommen werden wollen
also erstens hätte man es verhindern
können das ist eine ganz schwierige
frage die man sich sehr oft stellt und
die man sehr oft auch nicht beantworten
kann zweitens wir müssen natürlich nach
den vorgängen jetzt viel sorgsamer
warnsignale wahrnehmen uns darum kümmern
wir haben doch damals fallen jetzt den
versuch unternommen da vor ort runde
tisch es klingt ein bisschen salopp also
zusammenarbeit von polizei von leuten
die aus dem gesundheitsbereich kommen zu
kommen zu organisieren um miteinander
warnsignale zu besprechen also wenn es
menschen gibt bei denen solche
warnsignale vorgetragen werden ist es
klug dass man zumindest mal besprochen
hat nun abgewogen hat ob man etwas
unternehmen muss und wir haben jetzt
über 80 solche fälle schon miteinander
gesprochen auch und auch konsequenzen
gezogen zb dass jemand in eine klinik
eingewiesen wird zum beispiel dass die
polizei an schärferen blick drauf hat
und anderes mehr lückenlos 100 wird es
nie klappen ich finde das gehört auch
zur wahl dazu aber wir können besser
wenn er mich fest von überzeugt
ehrliche worte von ihnen besten dank
herr innenminister aus nrw